IN AUSTIN, TEXAS, --
PFLUGERVILLE WHERE THEY'VE BEEN
HAVING THIS PRESS CONFERENCE.
WE WILL MONITOR IT AND BRING YOU
ANY BREAKING NEWS.
GREG, I WILL GO TO YOU.
YOU HAVE A THEORY.
>> Greg: NOT A THEORY BUT KIND
OF -- IT'S OBVIOUSLY TERRORISM.
WE HAVE TO ADMIT THIS KIND OF
TERROR AS OPPOSED TO ISLAMIC
TERROR, IT IS STILL KIND OF A
RELIGIOUS FERVOR TERROR EXCEPT
IT'S THE MEDIA THAT'S THE
RELIGION THAT PROMISES THE
AFTERLIFE.
WHY DO PEOPLE DO THIS?
NOT TO GET 72.
IT'S TO GET 72 MILLION HITS ON
THEIR WIKIPEDIA PAGE.
THE MOTIVE IS ALWAYS GROWING
YOUR NUMERICAL SIGNIFICANCE.
WITH TECHNOLOGY, ONE ANGRY LOSER
CAN GET IN THE RECORD BOOKS BY
DOING THIS.
YOU HAD A COUNTRY PARALYZED.
IF YOU DECIDE IN LIFE THAT LIFE
ISN'T WORTH LIVING AND THAT YOU
HATE EVERYBODY AROUND YOU, THIS
IS THE WAY TO GET THERE.
EVIL THROUGH THE MEDIA PROVIDES
A CONSISTENT REWARD.
IT USED TO BE IN THE OLD DAYS IF
YOU LIVED IN A SMALL TOWN, YOU
HAD A COMMUNITY.
THAT PROVIDED YOU WITH YOUR
FEELING OF WORTH.
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ISOLATED AND THEY ARE BAD
PEOPLE, THIS IS VERY WORN.
SLEEPING ONE THING WE DON'T KNOW
YET, JESSE, IS MOTIVE.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANYTHING IN
HIS BACKGROUND?
HAS NO CRIMINAL RECORD.
NOT IN THE MILITARY.
HE WAS HOMESCHOOLED BY HIS MOM.
NO POLITICAL PARTY ON HIS VOTER
REGISTRATION.
BUT A GUY WHO WAS AN ELECTRICAL
ENGINEER GONE BAD, VERY BAD.
>> Jesse: COLLEGE DROPOUT,
LIVED WITH TWO ROOMMATES WHO
THEY ARE TALKING TO.
SUPPOSEDLY THEY ARE BEING VERY
COOPERATIVE.
>> Kimberly: THEY BETTER BE.
>> Jesse: THE TEXAS LAW
ENFORCEMENT GUYS AREN'T GOING TO
TAKE IT EASY ON THEM IF THEY
KNOW SOMETHING.
THERE WERE SOME WRITINGS WE
BELIEVE CAME FROM THIS PERSON.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT, HE WAS
AGAINST GAY MARRIAGE OR
SOMETHING ABOUT BEING FOR THE
DEATH PENALTY.
HE SAYS HE'S NOT A POLITICAL
PERSON.
I GUESS HE SAID HE LEANS
CONSERVATIVE.
WE DON'T KNOW YET IF THAT WAS
THE MOTIVATION, IF IT WAS
POLITICAL.
IF THERE IS A MANIFESTO OUT
THERE.
WE WILL KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT YET.
JUST TO GO BACK TO KIMBERLY'S
POINT, WE HAVE CRITICIZED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE FBI ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS FOR YEARS,
WHETHER IT'S POLICE BRUTALITY,
WHETHER IT'S THESE SHOOTINGS
THAT WERE BOTCHED,
INVESTIGATIONS OR FISA ABUSE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS
WHERE YOU HAVE TO SAY YOU GUYS
JUST DID AN AMAZING JOB.
TO PIECE TOGETHER THIS WITH THE
SPEED THAT THEY DID BY LOOKING
AT THE RECEIPTS AND MATCHING THE
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE AND THESE
BATTERIES THAT WERE ORDERED FROM
ASIA, I BELIEVE, VERY EXOTIC.
TO PING HIS PHONE AND SEE HIS
GOOGLE SEARCH HISTORY, TO DO
THAT IN A SHORT TIME FRAME AND
GET HIS CAR ENTAILED HIM UNTIL
HE BLEW HIMSELF UP.
WE WERE THINKING THIS COULD GO
ON FOR A WHILE.
THE UNABOMBER WENT ON FOR YEARS.
THIS GUY WAS OVER IN A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT DID AN AMAZING JOB.
I JUST WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU GUYS.
TO THE PEOPLE OF AWESOME COMMIT
SUCH AN AMAZING CITY.
I VISITED THERE SEVERAL TIMES.
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE THERE AND THE
GREAT SPIRIT.
AND THEY AREN'T BREATHING A SIGH
OF RELIEF YET BUT THE WORST IS
BEHIND US.
I CAN THINK NOW THEY CAN TAKE A
BREATH.
>> Dana: THEY ARE IN
PFLUGERVILLE, HIS MOTHER,
FATHER, AND SISTERS LIVED.
APPARENTLY THEY SAID THEY HAD NO
IDEA AND THEY SENT THEIR PRAYERS
TO THE VICTIMS.
>> Juan: THAT REMINDER OF WHAT
WE SAW AFTER THE VEGAS TERROR.
PEOPLE SAID THEY HAD NO IDEA,
EVEN THE GIRLFRIEND IN THAT
CASE, NO IDEA.
IN THIS CASE, I THINK EVERYONE
IS GOING TO BE HUNGRY FOR
MOTIVE, TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
THE LARGER PICTURE TO ME SEEMS
WE HAVE MORE OF THESE INCIDENTS,
WHETHER IT IS GUNS OR BOMBS.
PEOPLE LOOKING AT THIS WHEN THEY
PUT IT IN THE CATEGORY OF THE
UNABOMBER OR THE OLYMPIC PARK
BOMBER, SOMETHING CALLED THE
MIDWEST PIPE BOMBER.
THESE DIFFERENT BOMBINGS.
WE SEE MORE OF THESE OUTBREAKS
OF VIOLENCE, AND TOO OFTEN,
YOUNG MEN.
HAVING ARGUMENTS IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
IN OUR MEDIA, IN OUR HOLLYWOOD
STORIES, VIDEO GAMES AND THE
LIKE BUT ALSO MENTAL HEALTH.
BUT SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
IT'S HARD TO GET AWAY FROM IT
AND HARD NOT TO WORRY.
>> Greg: CAN I RESPOND TO
THAT?
YOUNG MEN ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
VIOLENCE BUT THEY ARE ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT OF THINGS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
NO, I'M JUST SAYING THAT THEY
FIGHT OUR WARS.
AND THEY ARE ALSO -- THEY ALSO
COMMIT A LOT OF CRIMES.
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY THIS IS A
MALE ISSUE.
WHENEVER ANYONE IS DOING A STORY
ON THIS, THE RELEVANT POINT IN
HISTORY IS THE UNABOMBER.
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOOD NEWS
BECAUSE THAT WAS 20 YEARS AGO.
SO THIS ACTUALLY ISN'T COMMON.
IT'S ACTUALLY RARE.
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK AND LOOK FOR SOMETHING THAT
WAS LIKE THIS, IT'S THE
UNABOMBER.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO '95 OR
'94 WHEN HE WAS CAUGHT.
I THINK THAT'S ENCOURAGING.
WE ALSO KNOW VIOLENCE IS ON THE
DECLINE.
WE KNOW THAT.
>> Jesse: TO YOUR POINT YOU
MADE BEFORE BUT EVIL AND HOW WE
COMPARE THIS KIND OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM TO ISLAMIC TERRORISM
IN THE UNITED STATES, I THINK
THE ISLAMIC TERRORISM IS MORE
FEARFUL ON OUR BEHALF BECAUSE
IT'S ABOUT AN OVERALL PHILOSOPHY
AND IDEOLOGY.
ITS WORLDWIDE AND HAS GOALS TO
TAKE OVER THE WORLD.
WHEREAS THIS IS SOMETHING LIKE,
THIS IS A DERANGED KID.
HE DOESN'T FIT INTO A CATEGORY.
THERE'S NO WAY TO KIND OF PUT
HIM INTO A CATEGORY.
WHAT ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO DO
ABOUT A PERSON LIKE THIS?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Juan: THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ARE STARTING TO HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND, THAT WE HAVE TO
BE BETTER.
WE HAVE TO PICK UP ON SIGNALS
MORE QUICKLY.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF IT.
GREG, I AGREE, IT'S ABOUT YOUNG
MEN FIGHT OUR WARS TOO.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION.
I DON'T SEE WOMEN DOING THIS.
>> Greg: OF COURSE.
IF YOU LOOK AT PRISONS, HOW MANY
WOMEN ARE IN PRISON VERSUS MEN.
WHEN YOU SAY THIS IS A PROBLEM.
WARD ARE WHITE MALES, MALES IN
GENERAL, AT A GENERAL AGE, HIGH
TESTOSTERONE CREATURES.
THEY ARE OFTEN INVOLVED IN A LOT
OF THINGS.
>> Dana: OUR PRODUCERS HAVE
BEEN MONITORING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T HAVE A
MOTIVE YET.
>> Kimberly: THERE'S A LOT OF
EVIDENCE LEFT IN THAT HOME, A
TREASURE TROVE.
THEY WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET A VERY DEEP PICTURE OF WHO
HE IS, WHAT MIGHT'VE MOTIVATED
HIM.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE ARE GOING TO
LEARN AND GET SOME UNDERSTANDING
FROM THIS.
IT WAS STOPPED AT AN EARLY
JUNCTURE WHICH IS CRITICAL,
ESPECIALLY FOR SOMEONE WHO